lots to talk about in the nfl world with
our friend from sports illustrated the
man who writes the mmqb
every single week my buddy albert breer
how are you albert
i'm good i'm good i kind of wish i had
some thursday night fall rich i uh
you know sometimes we poke fun and
everything else but then they take it
away from you and you kind of miss it
you know well you know what albert i'm
as you know i'm i've been at the
forefront of the uh everybody bash's
thursday night football
uh until you actually watch it uh
bus you know i've been driving that
after spending you know almost 10 years
sitting out on the set watching twitter
blow up about how terrible the game is
and then you know
a sunday or monday night game is 3-3
after the first half and nobody
complains about it
you know i've been i've been at the
forefront of that pretty much but hey
um but i'm glad you're pioneer in that
regard thank you so much
albert yeah you know but we did get a
wednesday game we didn't get a wednesday
game and
uh i've got one more sound bite from
mike tomlin to play
um you know that i'm curious to to to
play for you
uh and uh to get your thoughts on how
the steelers
reacted to everything from the league
this week this was mike tomlin
uh if that second soundbite you played
for me before the show don bowie
uh here here is what he had to say about
pr preparing now for the next game
mike you guys have a short week to
address any of
the problems that arose in this game do
you guys have enough time to turn things
around before you play
we don't have to reinvent the we don't
have to reinvent the wheel um
it's not some transformational thing
that needs to
to transpire we got to coach better and
play better when we get inside a bowl
and so i expect our group to do that on
monday night on monday evening whenever
it is that we play
okay so now tomlin uh
with that comment at the very end you
could tell um
he he's he's had enough of the schedule
changes uh how did the steelers
take this entire past week albert you
know i
i think like you you look at the record
rich
i mean they've handled it just about as
well as anybody and remember
and it's easy to forget this because it
feels like it was ten years ago now but
they were the team that was on the other
side of the titan situation
earlier in the year so they had their
bye week basically taken away from them
too
this you know would have represented um
you know this would have represented
like the mini buy and you know now
that's gone and so
it's just i mean you look at what the
steelers have been through
and you would think it'd be sort of a
worn out team
and um you know i think you got to give
them a lot of credit for the resilience
because
they've sort of been dealt a bad hand
when it comes to that
they've fought through that and and then
you look at some of the injury
situations and how they've been able to
find guys i mean
you know they lost devon bush was a and
you know as well as anybody how good a
player he can be
um a major part of their defense and
they've been able to kind of fill in for
him with guys like rob spelaine and now
they lose bud dupree
and so you know i i think one of the
things that
and it was interesting because i talked
to spleen after the game last night
and um he basically kind of told me what
mike tomlin said to them
back in july when they reported for
training camp we call it necessary
business in 2020 being able to kind of
take all these things that are going to
be different this year
and turn them into advantages for the
team and so uh
yeah i think they've been able to do
that the record certainly shows it you
know even in a day when they didn't have
their best game
um and i think that they you heard that
across the board from all the steelers
who spoke after the game
they they didn't feel like they played
very well they were still able to
come out in the right end of the
scoreboard as as they have every week
all year
bud dupree though right uh where we're
we're expecting a lot
it's it's how do they how do they come
back from that one
that that's that's a big one because now
that means yeah
presumably tj watt will get the
attention
that um he has not been getting because
some of it has to have been paid to
dupreeh
all season long right and you know like
that's the thing it's like dupreeh had
been
you know over the first you know four or
five years of his career
i think a little inconsistent great
athlete right he was really raw when he
was coming out of school as a first
round pick but she's a freak athlete and
was really starting to come into his own
and it sucks for him personally too
because i think he was really kind of
set up to cash in
on on everything that he'd done um over
the last year or so
and that's probably not going to happen
at least to the degree it was going to
happen
after this year and it's a huge loss for
the reasons that you mentioned there i
mean losing him
really means that if you're you know an
offense now
you can put to vote a ton of resources
of taking care of tj watt who
is absolutely defensive player of the
year candidate so not only do you lose
you know all dupries production you also
kind of lose the
impact that he had on on one of the best
defensive players in football and so
you know now they turn to a rookie um
you know and alex high smith who's
played a bunch for them
and made some key plays and a guy that
they really like um
it's a third round pick so it's not like
the guys come out of nowhere
um you know but they'll be leaning on
him a lot you know and
her defense has been playing really well
asking a lot more of him
and so it'll be interesting to see how
that that plays out because it did feel
after but i feel like after about like
eight or nine years of trying to rebuild
coming out of that like troy palamalu
james ferry or mark woodley james harris
in that era
they'd really struggle to put together
you know a great defense again and it
really
felt like they were right there albert
are here on the rich eisen show and in
terms of the steelers you know there's
no
like league bias towards the steelers i
mean if you really want to
uh you know if you really want to put a
fine point on it dan rooney was the one
who knocked on roger goodell's door
um you know a hotel room door to say
that the meeting had just broken and he
was the new commissioner of the nfl
so i mean but it is just the way the
cookie crumbles i guess that
the steelers have been on the you know
the the
wrong end one would say of the
scheduling stick
and and they have been undefeated
through all of that
so and i will touch on this subject with
ceo of the 49ers jed york
coming up at the top of the next hour uh
about
he was his team was on the short end of
a thursday night stick with
green bay coming to town and they were
they were highly short-handed
due to a late positive test that really
they weren't so sure was positive at the
time in kendrick born
what is what just for to lay it out here
the the
the rules by which the nfl decides to
push one game
six days or a game like denver
hosting the saints or that thursday
night packers at 49ers gotta go
i mean it doesn't matter how hamstrung
another team has got to go
what what what is this situation yeah
best you can tell well i mean first of
all first of all i think we're on track
to dispute this i think we're on track
for uh the league is scoring us
accusations for a single year
right right um so we'll probably we'll
probably wind up breaking that record
but that's
that's the circumstance we're all in you
know what i mean like and i think
um you know at the beginning of this in
july and august i remember like the
messaging that was coming out of 345
park and
i think some of those guys maybe wish
they had said it a little louder at the
time but
um you know what they were what they
were telling all of us was
they're going to be in equities and this
is going to be sideways
and there's going to come a point in the
year where it's not going to be fair
and we just have to accept that if
there's going to be football in 2020
this is just what everybody signed up
for
you know and so i think that was sort of
like the
that that's the message i've gotten
pretty consistently and again this isn't
revisionist history this is going all
the way back to the start in the summer
and really um you know like to answer
your question rich
like the actual standard right
is is spread of the virus contained
and they felt like the tennessee
situation
um it wasn't contained um they felt like
in this situation with baltimore it
wasn't contained and that was proven by
the fact that
the ravens got positive tests back like
just as they were boarding their flight
for pittsburgh and
they finally got to the point where they
felt like it was contained and they
could explain those two
but there was concern on the part of the
ravens players you know i can tell you
like they felt uneasy about getting on
that plane and so
you know i i think you know really the
standard here is
can the league prove that the spread of
covet 19
is contained in denver if you look at
like what happened there
really it was one case right like so it
was the case jeff driscoll
and then the other three quarterbacks
didn't have it but they were close
contacts
so like does that suck yeah it sucks
that value
that that's that's a really tough
circumstance for a team have to
to have to deal with is there medical
risk by putting the broncos in the field
in that case and not really right like
so
i think that's what you have to look at
like if you want to look at the league
and i
and i'm not saying that league's done
everything right here
um like across the board all year but i
mean i think they have been pretty
consistent on this that
if there's a medical risk we will look
at postponing games we will look at
potentially
if it comes to that at the end of the
year canceling games
um but if it's about a competitive issue
we're not gonna like that that that's
that's that's not gonna
fly like that's not gonna be the reason
why we postpone or cancel again because
the goal again
is to get all 256 games played a few
more minutes left here with albert breer
of
sports illustrated senior nfl reporter
the mmqb here on the rich eisen show
uh what do you know about breeze is this
do you think gonna be
uh the final start for taysom hill or or
it may last
further his uh breeze's absence due to
his ribs what are you hearing about
yeah i i think part of it's just going
to be like functionality you know and
and pain tolerance and those sorts of
things i can't like
i mean god if i crack one rib right uh i
know rich i have tried
i can't sleep like so i i
i like it basically it makes me cringe
thinking of what 11 crack grip
feels like uh so i think part of it's
going to be just how functional he can
be out there
and i and i don't think they're going to
know ahead of time like i think that's
the other part of it like
do they feel good about where he is and
then maybe he could start in a week or
two yeah
um will they know until he's there i
don't think they'll really know you know
and i think this is gonna have to be
a day-to-day thing based on the nature
of that injury and so
um look the good news is they've got a
team that we've seen as capable of
winning
um without being electric in the passing
game which i mean i i think
is if you look at past saints teams they
were so
reliant on drew brees in that passing
game it shows you what sort of spot that
roster's in
and um you know to win 31-3 even though
the broncos were in the situation they
were in
um and look at how dominant they were
throwing for under 100 yards
um i think it it shows you really where
the the saints are from a team
standpoint so i think having what i
believe
is the most well-rounded roster in
football right now
gives them some leeway to be patient
with drew brees if they want
if they want to be and um you know
really and what's the goal here the goal
is to have drew brees in the best
possible
place that you can on january 4th the
day after the regular season ends
and you're getting ready for the
playoffs and and the game saints falcons
uh is fascinating uh because of
what raheem morris has been able to do
um as the interim head coach
he and interestingly enough uh two big
uh division games
for the interim head coaches as romeo
cornell
just like raheem morris both teams four
and three under their interim head
coaches since the firings
of bill o'brien and uh dan quinn
respectively
do either of these guys have a shot at
the at the the 2021 gig
do you think albert i romeo cornell i'd
say no
um and i still think houston's figuring
out
a lot of things i'll put it that way um
and that
i i i like what road they're going to go
down as far as the general manager
what jack easterby's place in the
organization is you know
like whether or not like is it possible
like like he could be gone like there's
just i think there's a lot of unanswered
questions
in houston and i just i have a hard time
seeing where
they wouldn't you know they wouldn't be
resetting at the very least
the head coach of general manager
positions um
as for atlanta i do think raheem morris
has a really as
a very real chance there he's got a
relationship building
which mckay's of course worked with them
they both have ties back to tampa
um and i and i think you have to kind of
like rewind back to the beginning of
this year
and you know i i make calls on these
sorts of things over the summer
and um you know i raheem morris is one
of those names
who like all right like this guy's ready
for his second chance
and a lot of the reasons why people
liked him 10 years ago they're still
there and he's grown up a lot
and like the people in the atlanta
building really respond to him
and this is the second year in a row now
we've seen this sort of response
remember last year
when he was elevated to defensive
coordinator the
falcons caught fire and now you elevate
him to head coach
and they've caught fire again and so i
think you know a lot of the reasons why
people saw him as a potential head
coaching candidate back in the summer
those are still there and now he's
bolstering his case with how the team's
playing here
um down the stretch he's still really
young and you know i
i i i really think that this is a guy
who
could wind up being a really really good
find for somebody
in a second shot as head coach and it's
something i think the falcons have to
consider now
um you know you look at like anthony
lynn when
you know uh the bills fired rex ryan a
few years back
how anthony lynn really kind of showed
who he was and wound up earning the
chargers job off of what he had done as
a as an interim coach
um with the bills like i think we're
seeing the same sort of thing with
raheem and
maybe it's enough where where he doesn't
have to move and the falcons wind up
needing the head coach i'm not saying
that's
absolutely going to happen but i think
it's at least now in play i mean
if if um todd gurley had not
accidentally scored you know i mean they
they'd be
they'd be five and two one with them
yeah or five and
that's right five and one with him i
mean very very impressive
uh what's going on right there before i
let you go um have you used any of your
resources
to inquire whether the big ten will in
fact change
its rules about how many games a team
has to play in order to be eligible to
win
the conference championship with what's
going on with your
your buckeyes is that possible well i
think that's not all right
well as you know rich i'm about the
collective right like i'm really about
what the collective good of the big ten
conference no i know you weren't
like that's what i'm looking for that's
what i'm looking for and i like like is
this
a conference if is it good for the
conference if you're hurting the college
football playoff chance
chances of the conference well i mean
what's the point
in all honesty albert for the conference
honestly albert what is the point of
having gone through the season
if the season um the way that it has
gone
let's be honest here did give credence
to those who are like why are we playing
at all
but you have actually endeavored to play
why have a rule that is in place that
clearly
doesn't affect anything at all i mean i
i i think the rule was probably in place
that if
everybody was playing you know like if
one team was 6-0 and another team was
2-0
then that team that's 2-0 no matter how
many star recruit athletes they have
they shouldn't have a chance to
you know uh derail the 6-0 team you know
what i mean like i understand why having
the rule in place but the way that
things have gone
there is no reason to you know uh
what's the word for kneecap polax ohio
state's chances
of going somewhere because of everything
that's gone on with the virus there's no
so do you i know out barry alvarez
actually
said something about it yesterday saying
we should talk about changing the rule
do you think that can actually happen
yeah yeah i do and i think it's like and
i think it's
just you know like look like i don't
think we can
i don't think we can look at rules that
we but like in every sport like rules
that we basically
all made up on the fly right so these
aren't rules that have been in place for
30 years
no you made it up that you had to play
six games in this in this pandemic you
had to play at least six
right games based on what you knew in
september and so is it that crazy to
make up a rule
to change the rule now based on what you
know in december no and i
and i do think like one of the things
that's key here is the head-to-head too
you know i mean like like how how would
you look at indiana like is that a
legitimate big ten championship if
indiana
winds up say ohio state like say the
college football playoff puts them in
and you know ohio state wins the
national championship right
and they do it after playing in the
second place game
in the big ten so they play against
wisconsin that that championship weekend
like does anyone remember indiana as the
real big ten champion then
no like you know like so i mean i i
think tom allen and those guys have done
a great job at indiana they deserve a
ton of credit but they didn't beat ohio
state
they didn't beat her but they lost the
head-to-head in that game
if you watch that game like to some like
the indiana
great heart ohio state went up 35 to 7
and fell asleep
you know what didn't mean like so no i
know i don't know
that's what i'm saying part of me you're
right you can change the rule i think
that the
the ncaa or the fbs writ large should
should change everything like it's like
why are we
why are we sitting here watching byu's
schedule coastal carolina so both sides
can
beef up their resumes when we could just
expand the playoffs and let everyone
play and not cross vectors
nationally until when it's all on the
line like what what are we
doing is essentially that to me what i'm
saying rich thank you
thank you that to me like like that to
me is so perfect like
like wouldn't this be like if you were
the college football player wouldn't
this be the perfect year
to just float the trial balloon or the
18 playoff and see how it works
like right not right baseball expanded
more playoffs
right exactly because i mean like you me
and
you know what you get a free look at
what it looks like exactly right
right like so so you can go back to four
teams next year
or maybe it works so well that you want
to go to eight teams permanently right
like i
like they had they have like a free shot
and potentially going to eight teams
here or even 16 if you really want to
get crazy about it
like but like either way like you have
this free shot at it there's like
logical reason to do it
i'm with you a hundred percent so
florida in there throw texas a m in
there
throw byu in there throw cincinnati in
there and like
i just think it would be so much fun to
have that sort of thing
and i i can't imagine any school would
be against that
um and like look like if it really works
and if it's you know something like
something you were thinking about anyway
which i think that they have thought
about
expanding the playoffs why not in this
weird different environment
why not just take a shot at it and if it
works
great if not you go back to four teams
and you know nobody's worse for the
where i know we're up against it in the
radio business and i apologize to our
radio partners for going a little bit
longer with albert breer here but
while i am being reasonable and have
shown my uh reasonableness by pounding
the table for ohio state and the big
tent
um can we all agree it's insane to
suggest michigan is ducking ohio state
using covet as a shield
yeah maybe to try and recap your chances
i i had some we can we agree
on that i i had some fun with that but
you know what like
what i know about jim harbaugh
what i know about jim harbaugh having
covered him when he was in san francisco
um i don't think that's really in his
personality to do that
i just like like he's he's a as you know
as well as anyone rich he's a different
dude like
[ __ ] people is not in his personality
yes and his personality by saying don't
eat chicken because it's a nervous bird
yes that's there but ducking
ducking is uh is that's okay i'm glad
i'm glad we can at least agree on that
in part and yeah i mean i had some fun
with it earlier in the week but like
you know and that's like i i think it's
kind of a funny idea but like there's no
i like i don't think those kids would
want to duck ohio state and they
certainly don't think that
coach would want to i mean i remember
watching him
coach in 2014 the building was like on
fire in san francisco
right like that thing was i mean that
was not a good situation
and you know what like that team kept
swinging until the end and you had to
get
this is the one thing at the end of all
of that like that anybody no matter what
you thought of jim like
you had to give him credit like that
team kept swinging all the way to the
end so
i can't imagine that like he would be
concocting some plan to try and duck
ohio state
or try to screw them out of the playoffs
just doesn't seem like that's in his
personality yeah and using covet is that
cudgel as well
um albert thank you for the call
appreciate it you take care i'll read
your stuff on monday as always and let's
uh let's stay in touch
we'll have you back awesome awesome stay
safe out there all right guys back at
you that's albert
you're on the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here